you are watching confusion TV
[Music]
I welcome to another ColdFusion video
since their founding in 1976 by a
business savvy hippie and a nerd Apple
has had a unique place in the tech
market today there are polarizing entity
but historically Steve Jobs has always
made sure that Apple products were
accessible to non-technical people
making things easy to use opened up the
door to a much wider market despite this
strategy things haven't always gone
their way in the 1990s Apple lost the PC
Wars and we're failing it would take
Bill Gates in 1997 to save them with a
150 million dollar investment and lastly
Microsoft is making an investment in
Apple Microsoft is buying a hundred and
fifty million dollars worth of Apple
stock and I happen to have a special
guest with me today via satellite
downlink and if we could get him up on
the stage right now
it would only be after the return of
Steve Jobs and the release of the iPod
in 2001 that would make Apple a tech
cultural icon for the 21st century the
iPhone only solidified this as mentioned
in the previous video
Apple recently crossed the one trillion
dollar mark this is more than the GDP of
Mexico or Indonesia or turkey although
this is just a market valuation Apple
does actually have stockpiles of real
profit so the question must be asked
just how does Apple make so much money
[Music]
the original iPhone was a groundbreaking
device the breakthrough of using your
own fingers to seamlessly navigate a
pocket device with smart software made
the iPhone absolutely crush former
Mobile Kings Nokia and Blackberry were
obliterated and the mobile touch
software combination sparked to shift
the force Microsoft and Intel to the
sidelines as it turned out people just
simply valued a pocket computer that was
easy to use after its launch in 2007 the
iPhone gradually replaced the iPod as
Apple's biggest revenue driver with this
being said it shouldn't be any surprise
that Apple makes most of us money from
the iPhone about 70% of its profits come
from this device between 2008 and 2017
the number of iPhones shipped search
from 11.6 million to 216 million units
during the same period Apple's annual
revenue soared over 600 percent in terms
of raw profit Apple manages to produce
iPhones for $370 or less and sell them
for an average price of 720 dollars and
of course the iPhone intends chips 5
over $1000 to support this high price
Apple has positioned their products as
luxury devices other companies sell the
devices are much thinner margins to give
you an idea
Apple rakes in 86 percent of the entire
smartphone industries profits
despite controlling just 24 percent of
the global market interestingly the
iPhone 10 alone takes in 35 percent of
all profits of the entire industry
okay so that's kind of interesting but
we have to ask the question is Apple too
reliant on smartphone sales in reference
to the smartphone market Tim Cook's
recently said in an analyst conference
call quote whether it grows by 1 or 2%
by 5% or shrinks it's still a huge
market in quote and Tim's right as long
as iPhone sales are rising
year-over-year things are good but
eventually iPhone sales will slow so you
might be wondering how could I be so
sure that they will slow well above all
else market saturation simply put pretty
much everyone who wants a smartphone has
one and to add to this with powerful
Android phones coming out for as little
as $300 the market is more accessible
than ever before yes some people might
want to upgrade their phone every year
but as phones gradually become good
enough at everything in a few years less
and less people were going to upgrade
not only this but the iPhone isn't the
only great phone out there right now
there was a time when the iPhone was
miles ahead of anything else in the
market but that's simply not the case
anymore if Apple doesn't make drastic
changes after a while the interest in
the iPhone will only last so long when
iPhone sales finally fade Apple needs
new products and services to pick up the
slack but in the meantime they have
another way of making money I've heard
so many of my friends say I've had a few
iPhones and I'm liking them less and
less but I don't want to change to
Android because I'll lose all of my
stuff even though one of my friends has
an iPhone
she called Apple the cult of the tech
world for trapping her in their
ecosystem
the combination of Apple's walled
software garden and brand loyalty makes
the iPhone ideal bait for growing Apple
service business Apple services are
things like the App Store iTunes Apple
music iBooks Apple care and Apple pay
after iPhone users start buying their
apps and media from the App Store and
iTunes they're much less likely to leave
behind their purchases by switching to
Android devices Tim Cook is very aware
of this and he has repeatedly stated
that Apple plans to grow its software
services to offset the gradual slowdown
of iPhone sales because of this the
services section of Apple is becoming
more and more important as time goes on
as the smartphone market shrinks Apple
has to make more money out of the market
that they've acquired from iPhone users
the company hopes to double their
services revenue by 2020 and it appears
to be on track to be doing so Apple's
locking strategy also helps as well
their upgrade program lets people pay
for iPhones and a monthly basis for two
years after 12 months users can switch
to the latest iPhone and reset the
payment process Apple can make a bit of
extra cash by selling accessories for
example some of the best-selling Apple
products right now aren't the iPhone but
dongles and ear pods mainly because of
the removal of the headphone jack from
the iPhone standard USB dongles on the
MacBook Pro are also hot sellers
[Music]
okay so I was going to put advertising
as a reason for Apple success but I have
a feeling that Apple's advertising isn't
working as effectively as a once did the
direct advertising might not be as
powerful but in the age of reality TV
the status symbol aspect of Apple's
brand is working pretty much all major
celebrities use iPhones and whenever
there's media coverage on that celebrity
in question there they are with an
iPhone or MacBook after a while this
free advertising the Apple device has
become a status symbol in their own
right for impressionable people this may
mean that the iPhone is the only phone
worth getting further driving Apple
sales so I think the secret to apples
success is multi prompt but not entirely
a surprise
I think Tim Cook has pushed the company
into a strictly business attitude under
his lead Apple has found ways to
generate more profit from higher margins
aggressively kept consumers in the Apple
ecosystem and made dongles a top seller
but that being said there's a large part
of me that wonders where has the Apple
of old gone the iPod iPhone and even Mac
were old transformative products it
really has been a while and I'm sure
consumers would love to see another
major innovation the Apple watch and
home pod were just not it Apple II isn't
running out of money anytime soon so
they're not in trouble and it doesn't
really matter what they do in the end
but the room is no longer empty
Microsoft has caught on to the idea of
trendy things with projects like the
surface lion and hololens or project
Andromeda
maybe Apple has something be up their
sleeve but the world isn't going to wait
forever anyway so that's my take on how
Apple makes so much money thanks for
watching this has been to gogo you've
been watching cold fusion if you've just
stumbled across this channel feel free
to subscribe and if you know someone
that will be interested in this topic
feel free to share this video with them
alright and I'll see you again soon for
the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]